Dawn raids is how they've been operating
recently Israeli forces move in fast
while Palestinians sleep
in the last few weeks this has become a
daily routine in occupied East Jerusalem
and the rest of the occupied West Bank
this time they're sealing the family
home of Palestinian hasin karaka
on Friday the father of three slammed
his car into a bus stop near the illegal
settlement to Vermont three Israelis
were killed including two sibling
children
on Sunday the weekly cabinet meeting
turned its attention to the frequency of
these attacks three in just two weeks
or carried out by Young Palestinians
including a 13 year old or from occupied
East Jerusalem and all operating alone
and so the new Israeli government wants
to send a strong message
the appropriate answer to terror is to
strike hard and further deepen Our Roots
in our country accordingly the cabinet
is meeting today to prepare for an even
broader action against those carrying
out terrorism and their supporters in
East Jerusalem and Judea and Samaria
while preventing as much as possible
harming those uninvolved
but family and friends of the attackers
say they too are being targeted in what
they've described as collective
punishment through Mass arrests raids
and demolitions of homes dozens of
Palestinians have already been killed by
Israeli forces this year alone
Israel's most right-wing government
hasn't been in power for long but it's
already facing major hurdles apart from
the Palestinian issue it's also facing
accusations of trying to undermine your
Judiciary and move the country away from
democracy
Saturday saw the biggest Nationwide
anti-government protest in weeks more
than 145
000 people stood in cold weather ahead
of the first of several knesset votes to
curb judiciary powers some have called
for an end to Israel's ruling Coalition
which has far-right Ultra nationalist
parties including ministers with
convictions ranging from racism to the
Prime Minister himself who's on trial
for corruption
foreign
Netanyahu has dismissed these protests
as a refusal to accept the last election
results
Al Jazeera West Jerusalem